quand on parle d'elle on la surnomme la
deudeuche lula deux pattes vous l'aurez
compris je veux parler de la halle de
chevaux et rachid elle a aujourd'hui 50
ans nous allons plonger dans les
archives de cette de chevaux pour
évoquer cet anniversaire avec luc bazin
est tout de suite avec jean jacques
dufour et pierre moskowitz qui nous
emmène faire un tour avec les
inconditionnels de cette voiture dont la
fabrication a été arrêtée en 90
seulement quand on cause bagnole avec un
amoureux de cette fabuleuse boîte de
conserve qui elle a deux beaux on évoque
bien sûr ni l'odeur des cuirs ni la
puissance des bx4 125 dans toute sa
splendeur
une voiture qui était donné pour combler
dans les années 60
ben non le cahier des charges était 60 à
l'heure au début au début c'était elle
et des consuls pour emmener quatre
personnes à 60 à l'heure voilà et puis
celle là où la 80 90 et les derniers
modèles on arrive à faire des pointes à
120 l'heure quand même 120 le sens
vannes le vent dans le dos 1
pour les amateurs de deux pattes la
vitesse n'est pas un argument d'ailleurs
à l'époque de la conception chez citroën
le bonheur d'être clair soyez
sordidement économe et oui le plus de
cette auto ce sont ces mois elle n'a
qu'un oeil
enfin qu'un phare est seulement une
manivelle pour la mettre en route
vous l'avez reconnu c'est la deux
chevaux et aux l'ancêtre de la deux
chevaux
le prototype vrai pour le salon 1939
alain glatt inique qui a le même âge que
ce formidable moulin à légumes acheté sa
première 268 depuis il les collectionne
tombe amoureux de cette bagnole ça
s'explique pas
question ambiance de riz à propos de
rythme entre 49 et 50 les cadences de
production commence tu as milliers et
passe de 5 à mille véhicules par jour ça
marche et c'est logique puisque tout a
été fait pour séduire une clientèle qui
est encore essentiellement rural à la
campagne l'engin est idéal pratique et
confortable elle doit dit son cahier des
charges pouvoir transporter un panier de
à travers champs sans les casser
ça c'est un argument de vente elle peut
le faire
la fai mais la deux chevaux a fait
beaucoup plus raide rallye c'est l'idéal
pour les échappées belles
jacques séguéla s'en souvient en 59 avec
elle il a fait le tour du monde
surtout c'était une voiture convivial
c'est une voiture qui vous ouvrez la
porte des autres qui vous ouvrez le
coeur des autres
je vais arriver aux états unis tu es
notre premier arrêt aux bandeaux pub
ligne n'a vu un américain septuagénaire
descendre et de dire ses formes d'art
vous l'avez compris vous même quand on
guette celui qui l'énoncé culture il a
été tellement abasourdi de savoir que
les français préfèrent ça qui nous a
invité à déjeuner à dire depuis l'arrêt
de la production 90 les fidèles ne
manque jamais l'occasion d'un
regroupement celui là c'était l'été
dernier des petites voitures qui ont
réussi l'exploit de gommer les
différences sociales de la star à
l'ouvrier tout le monde pouvait en avoir
une de france a c'est un mythe dans tous
les pays ayant les deux fronts
c'est la voiture c'est que nos deux
chevaux l'orage veut même pas entendre
parler ça glisse tout bois
cela dit et ça fait mal au coeur des
amoureux de la belle il y à des jeunes
gens qui refusent tout contact avec elle
des jeunes qui pensent peut-être qu'à 50
balais on ne peut plus plaire alors vous
êtes très enfin vous me disiez qu'il
n'était pas très fan peut en revanche
pas du tout
mes enfants et n'est pour rien au monde
on utilisera une deux chevaux gens leur
permis dans leur voiture mais pour rien
au monde utilisent windows chaud et le
pire c'est ma fille qui a 12 ans
caroline qui refusent que je la dépose
devant l'école devant le lycée et au
collège avec une 2 chevaux les filles
partir de 28 ans de 20 ans serait plutôt
attirée n'est pas le messie par les
petites filles préférés tels les
bagnoles clinquante et tape à l'oeil
je ne sais pas mais dans le doute je
préfère tirer le rideau